إنه يحب كرة القدم ويحب
الهواتف التي تجلس في مركز للاجئين في
الضفة الغربية. لا تستطيع خادمة إسماعيل عبد حبس
دموعه عندما يتحدث عن
عائلته، وزوجته وأطفاله الخمسة في
غزة الذين تعرضوا للتو لقصف متواصل
خلال
الأسبوع الماضي.  "إنها حياتي بالطبع، فهي
كل حياتي،
يجب أن يكون إسماعيل هناك أيضًا عندما
اندلعت الحرب، كان في إسرائيل، حصل ما يقرب من
18000 جوينز على تصريح للعمل
هناك، كنت أرغب دائمًا في الحصول على هذا التصريح
لأن الوضع في غزة سيئ للغاية، والوضع
المالي  الديون
الاقتصاد
صفر الآن هو فقط يريد العودة إلى
ديارهم في هذه الحالة الآن سأعود
هذه اللحظة أود أن أعود عندما
نفذت حماس هجومها في جنوب
إسرائيل وجد المئات من هؤلاء العمال المحدقين
أنفسهم فجأة عالقين
بعيدًا عن منازلهم  عائلات مع بدء
سقوط القنابل على قطاع غزة، يوجد الآن عدة
مئات من هؤلاء العمال هنا في
مخيم ديسا للاجئين في انتظار العودة إلى
ديارهم. من الصعب حقًا التعامل مع هذه الأرقام،
وقد يكون هناك 15
20,000 تصريح عمل يتم إصدارها يوميًا
يوميًا، لا نعرف عدد الأشخاص الذين كانوا
يعملون يوم السبت،
لذلك ربما كان العدد إلى النصف، وربما
أكثر من ذلك، أكثر من 10,000 أوم، لكن
الإسرائيليين قاموا
بجمعهم وإحضارهم إلى
الضفة الغربية على الأقل.  180 شخصًا يعيشون نائمين
وينتظرون هنا في
مركز الأحداث في مخيمات اللاجئين التابعة لإدارة مكافحة المخدرات وهم عاجزون بشكل مؤلم عن
مساعدة
أسرهم، ما الذي أشعر به أشعر أنني
لا أستطيع النوم أنا قلق جدًا عليهم وأنا
على اتصال بهم طوال اليوم
وحتى الآن تحدثت مع ابني وقلت له
أن يغادر ويذهب إلى منطقة أخرى ويأخذ
أمك وإخوتك ويذهب إلى
منطقة أخرى إذا كنت هناك سأكون أنا من
يأخذهم من مكان إلى آخر
لحمايتهم فمن  من يعتني
بعائلتك
الآن
لا أحد، نحن جميعًا موجودون جسديًا هنا
ولكن عقولنا في
غزة، لا أفعل
خلال مقابلتنا حاولت عائلة مروان
الاتصال به مرتين، وكان أكثر ما كان
مؤلمًا عند الاستماع إلى
قصص هؤلاء الرجال هو الشعور
العجز هم جميعاً أرباب
عائلاتهم وعادة ما
يكونون هم الذين يأخذون عائلاتهم من
مكان إلى آخر بحثاً عن الشعور
بالأمان مع سقوط القنابل على
قطاع غزة، وبدلاً من ذلك فهم بعيدون عن
عائلاتهم العالقة في الضفة الغربية.
يحاولون توجيه عائلاتهم عبر
الهاتف إلى أين يذهبون أه، وقد حصلنا أيضًا على
بعض الأرقام الجديدة من
وكالة الأمم المتحدة للاجئين المكلفة باللاجئين
الفلسطينيين، حيث يقولون إنه يُعتقد أن أكثر
من 4100 من هؤلاء العمال المحظوظين
كانوا في إسرائيل عندما قامت حماس
نفذت هجومها الإرهابي في
جنوب إسرائيل، ويعتقد الآن أن جميعهم
تقطعت بهم السبل في أميرة الضفة الغربية